There are few things in the world that are
more mysterious than how we come off to other
people.
Well, beside sex.
And black holes...those have always confused
me.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here for DNews.
Self awareness can only take you so far in
life, since everyone that you're interacting
with will interpret you differently.
Now a new study coming out of Columbia University
is casting light on just how out-of-touch
we really are.
The researchers were looking specifically
at the issue of assertiveness; are you as
assertive as you think you are?
Participants were paired up to make a deal
with each other, then they were surveyed about
their own assertiveness as well as their partners.
For those that *came off as under assertive*,
most of them thought they were appropriately
pushy, or maybe even too pushy, during the
negotiations.
For the participants that *came off as overly
pushy*, most of them thought they came off
us just the right amount or not assertive
enough.
So, the odds of you correctly assessing how
you come off to others(?) is 50/50.
Which basically means you could be a JERK
or a PUSHOVER and you'd never know it!
There's one other important finding though:
those who came off as just the right amount
of assertive tended to think that they had
been a little too assertive.
So, when in doubt, be a little more assertive
than you think you should be, and you may
get closer to striking that golden balance.
Cash money in the bank baby.
Assertiveness isn't the only area where our
self perception is a little off.
Other studies have also found that we tend
to perceive ourselves as more attractive than
we really are -- something called "self enhancement
bias".
For the study, researchers took pictures of
participants and subtly photo shopped them
into several versions.
When asked to select their original photo,
people selected the one that was enhanced
to look more attractive.
When they were selecting photos of a stranger
they had briefly met, the participants picked
the unmodified photo.
Self enhancement bias comes into play with
our perception of our own *goodness* as well.
A study at Cornell found that we overestimate
how charitable we are.
We consistently estimate that we'll give more
to charity than we actually do.
We predict others' donations pretty well though.
Same for our self-perception of voting behavior:
we overestimate our likelihood of do that
good citizen duty of voting.
It kind of makes you question your life and
the universe and everything you once knew.
WHO ARE YOU, IN THIS WORLD?
I guess you'll never know.
Thanks for joining me for DNews everyone,
we'll be back later with more science updates.